>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Dan Morgenstern: This
is a kind of a reunion
because Abdullah Ibrahim and
I have not seen each other
in a very long time.
But we do go back to New York
where he had recently arrived,
and we did manage to spend
some time together there.
And it was wonderful to see
you again, looking great
and sounding marvelous, there
was a concert last night
of your trio, which was beautiful.
And we've had a chance to talk a
while and reminisce a little bit
and I think what we're
going to do now is to find
out about all the things that you've
been up to since then [laughter],
which would probably
take us about a year and.
But to begin with, I
remember that one of the thing
that we did together was a concert
at, in the garden at the Museum
of Modern Art in New York.
And that was a great evening,
and I'm sure that you remember
a little bit about that.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yes, I do.
And Dan, thank you.
It's great to see you again,
and you are looking very well.
Always fond memories, and
my deepest appreciation
because when I first
came to New York,
you really supported
me like 100 percent.
And I'll always remember
that, very, very kind of you.
I remember this concert
very vaguely [laughter].
>> Dan Morgenstern: Yeah, it
was with the Choir of Lancaster.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim:
Oh [inaudible], yeah!
>> Dan Morgenstern: And
Morris [assumed spelling],
who was a fellow South African,
and Sonny Brown was the drummer.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yeah.
>> Dan Morgenstern: And
I found their review
from Down Beat way back, and let's
see, Junior Booth was the bassist.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim:
Junior Booth, yeah.
He just, he just arrived in New
York shortly He was from Buffalo.
Great bass player.
Alright. You know, I remember that,
and then I went on to form a trio
with the Bad Lancaster and
Kello Scott [assumed spelling],
the cellist.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Oh, Kello Oh,
he was a wonderful player, yeah.
Yeah, he just made a handful
of records, not enough.
And people don't know
about him anymore, no.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: No.
>> Dan Morgenstern: And that was
such an unusual instrument and, and.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Of course, you
know, cello, and I was interested
in playing cello since I was a kid.
When I got to New York, I got a
little cello and started playing.
But then, I met Kello, and Kello
also introduced us to kodaly.
And of course, kodaly cello
suites, really resonates with,
also with our dynamic
of our understanding,
how can we expand the harmonic
and rhythmic possibilities.
So I formed a trio with Bad
Lancaster on bass clarinet,
and Kello on cello,
and myself on piano.
And then I went to a New York
club, I can't remember where he was
and I said, would you like
to book me, I've got a trio?
They said fine, but when we
pieced off the other night,
they didn't want to play me,
because that's not a trio.
You see a trio is bass,
drums [laughter].
So it took me 50, 60
years to create it again,
and that was the unit
that we saw last night.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Yes.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim:
This was the idea.
>> Dan Morgenstern: That was a,
it's a beautiful combination.
It really, it's a special sound
because there is doubling
and [inaudible].
We heard quite a bit of piccolo.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Piccolo.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Which is an
instrument you don't encounter too
often, I guess, and he
played it beautifully.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Incredible,
incredible, wonderful player.
And also Cliff Guyton, flute player,
cello, and clarinet, and piccolo.
The cello and bass
player, Noah Jackson,
this is his first gig
out of college.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Really?
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: He came out
of college last year and joined us,
and quite, I think there's
a, the younger generation of,
of musicians who, technically
skilled, but also have the passion,
and also lock into the tradition.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Well he's a
fine cellist and it's interesting.
Again, usually when the
cello was used in jazz,
it was pizzicato, [inaudible].
>> Abdullah Ibrahim:
[inaudible] yeah.
Yeah, Kello Scott [assumed
spelling] at that time told me,
he said he'd play it amplified.
He amplified the cello and slung
it, and then stood up with it.
So I ask him to tell
me, why do you do this?
And he said, "I wanted to get
away from the drummer" [laughter].
Because the only place you're right
to the drummer and amplify it.
>> Dan Morgenstern: I saw Kello, I
think not with you unfortunately,
but I saw him live
once at the Half Note,
which was a nice club in downtown.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yeah,
I remember the Half Note.
>> Dan Morgenstern: They
had very good food too,
which was unusual [inaudible]
At the Velvet Shrinegard
[phonetic], they had nothing.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Exactly.
>> Dan Morgenstern: So,
how long did you stay
in New York at that time in the 60s?
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: It
was quite a long time.
We stayed at least
thirty, thirty years,
thirty years at various,
various places.
But then we ended up at the
Chelsea Hotel, that's where we ended
up staying for quite a
long time with [inaudible].
And I had come from Cape Town to New
York like a scouting party to come
and look for accomodation, you
see, and the family would follow.
And then Don Cherry [assumed
spelling] introduced me
to [inaudible], who was the
manager of the Chelsea Hotel,
and that's where we stayed
at a colony of artists.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Yes, the
Chelsea was a famous hotel on 23rd.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim:
23rd street, yeah.
But before it was because the
children had to go to school,
it was a walk away, anywhere that
you wanted to go, you want to go
down to the village, yeah.
>> Dan Morgenstern: That's a good
location, and then as you say,
you know, a lot of
artists lived there.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yeah.
>> Dan Morgenstern:
Interesting people.
And it was more or less
of a residential hotel.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: It
was residential, yeah.
And then a few years, over two or
three years ago, it all changed
when it changed ownership.
Yeah so then, we had to move out.
>> Dan Morgenstern: But then,
it took some time before
you went back home.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yeah,
I went back shortly in 70,
74 and then it became like most,
for most of us during that time,
it became totally unbearable.
Because it was very,
very suppressive.
And then we left, and
then didn't return
until Mandela was released
from prison in 98.
>> Dan Morgenstern:
And you performed
at Nelson Mandela's inauguration.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yeah.
>> Dan Morgenstern:
What was that like?
That must have been special.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Thing that
I remember most that we had this,
it was only like unconscious fear
that we were not supposed
to be there, you know?
Because it happens to
all of us, so suddenly.
A place like Pretoria, where you'll
even be weary during those years
to walk, to walk the streets.
And it was, it was exhilarating
and it was something confusing also
because it was too much
to handle [laughter].
Too much to handle at the same time,
but the inauguration was very
remarkable because there were close
to a million people
at the Union Building.
So we never could go, I never went.
And for me, I mean, it went
on for hours and hours,
I met all the musicians and
other artists who performed.
But the display was incredible,
because it was a military display
of strength, and just to
see how they then managed
to handle this transition
without major conflict.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Yeah well there
have been some tremendous changes
there over your lifetime.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yes.
Those are, we always
understood that the period
after the change would
be very, very difficult.
And there's some of the
problems that we face now.
Because in some ways, we were not,
we didn't prepare ourselves
to handle it properly.
But I'm quite amazing, in
spite of all the negativity,
there are people there
who are unsung
and working behind the
scenes, very dedicated,
and also very knowledgeable, and
also have the vision for the people.
So we are, we're hopeful.
>> Dan Morgenstern: You make
your home now in Cape Town,
is that where you have your
sort of main residence?
Because you travel so much.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Right now,
I'm at the Hyatt [laughter],
Hyatt Regency Washington, but I have
a base with my fiancé in Germany.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Where?
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Chiemsee.
>> Dan Morgenstern:
Chiemsee is beautiful.
My grandmother had a place
not far from Chiemsee.
So I knew that region,
when I was a child.
Yeah.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yeah
well, quite, quite beautiful.
So my fiancee, Dr Marina O
Marie [assumed spelling],
she's a medical doctor.
And so she invited me to come
because at some point I
had a illness that I had
to go ahead to deal with.
And through her assistance
the problem was solved.
And this is one of the reasons why
I live there, the other reason was
that most of the work at
that time was in Europe.
So to commute from
South Africa to Europe
in the Northern Hemisphere
was a bit tricky.
And also, my dream in [inaudible],
of course, when European is in,
you've got an instrument like
that, you have to have hope.
And so Fazioli [assumed spelling]
factory, is about four hours drive
from where we are [inaudible].
So it's just across the border.
So I know Paulos, from very first
years when he started playing piano.
So he invited me to his factory, I
did a concert there and then I said,
okay, let me try and
buy an instrument,
but now you must have
a home to put it.
So that's why I'm in
Chiemsee, beautiful instrument.
>> Dan Morgenstern: I don't
think I've ever seen one,
they're not mass manufactured,
I think.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: No, he is a,
I think he creates about 100 or 50
or 75, but it takes time to mature.
It's very meticulous on the sound,
and the materials that he uses.
And the instrument is very,
it's an incredible instrument,
one of the instrument that
really resonates with you.
You don't have to fight with it.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Well, I can
imagine that that is very important
to you because you get such a
beautiful sound from the piano.
You have a very special
touch and you, you know,
you just create a very special kind
of feeling from that instrument.
Some people use it vey precursiely,
but you have a really
beautiful, almost romantic way.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim:
Oh, thank you very much.
[Inaudible] it comes,
it comes through,
through trial, trial and error.
Which is what, what is the best
method to, to transmit what you,
what you're really feeling?
And I discovered that if you just
work acoustically with the sound
in the venue, instead of
amplifying everything first.
If we play bigger concerts,
for example, with a group,
I suggest to the sound engineers
that we first play acoustically.
And we can hear each other on stage,
and then transport this into the,
you know, into the whole And
[inaudible] sense of technique
that I can, I can actually hear,
at what level of volume I should
strike the note for it to reach,
you know, to fill the space.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Well,
it's started with so much music
is over-amplified these days.
And unnecessarily, I mean
there are clubs in New York
where you could hear perfectly
well without, you know,
having a bunch of microphones
on stage.
But they always put them there,
and once they amplify the drums,
then they have to amplify
everything else [laughter].
I once did something, I had a very
short career as a concert producer.
It wasn't anything that I did
primarily, but [inaudible]
with George Wayne who asked
me to do a few things.
And I wanted there because
Carnegie Hall has such great sound.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yeah.
>> Dan Morgenstern: And
when Stan gets played there,
sure thing he said,
turn off the mic.
Everybody would, you know, looked
at each other, what does he mean?
[inaudible]
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yeah.
So I got the idea doing a duet
at a concert of acoustic duets
at Carnegie Hall, and it
came out quite nicely.
Abdullah Ibrahim Yeah.
So far as we normally play acoustic,
if it's a larger venue then we ask
the engineer just to put a touch
of it on, and work
from the natural sound.
Sometimes the engineers have
to earn their keep, you see.
So they have to be seen [laughter].
>> Dan Morgenstern: They don't want
to be made obsolete, of course.
So, you spent some time at
the Library of Congress,
which is where we are now.
Did you find it interesting?
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Quite
amazing, kind of amazing.
I had no, I had no idea the scope
and quality, it's quite something,
I was totally, totally blown away.
And of course, looking over
at Larry, he introduced me,
and then took out some of the,
you know, the scores and charts.
You see that some of them I've been
trying to track down for some time.
Remember I've been looking
at the Ellington's turquoise,
on a turquoise cloud.
And, so, Larry showed
me, showed me the charts.
And incredibly, you know, you
remember that Ellington asked me
to work tempo music in New York.
He asked me to help pull it, pull
the publishing company together.
And also I used to transcribe
some of his, some of the music.
The Virgin Island suite, when it
came back from, they just had tapes.
You see, so I transcribed it,
and then submitted it, you see.
And then I hd some of
my own compositions.
So when Larry pulled this Ellington,
they were my transcription.
>> Dan Morgenstern:
My transcription.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim There all
so, and you feel quite honored.
>> Dan Morgenstern:
That's fascinating
and it's completely off tempo,
but just about two weeks ago,
I re-listened to that Virgin Island
suite for the first time in years.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim:
Really [laughter]
>> Dan Morgenstern: Maybe
I had a premonition.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: I
remember, where was it again?
And Larry showed me the
address also of tempo music
But his sister was running,
it was in his sister's house.
In Ruth's house.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Yeah.
Did you ever visit Ruth in
her apartment in New York?
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: That's
where the publishing company was.
>> Dan Morgenstern:
Everything was white.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yes [laughter].
>> Dan Morgenstern: It
was an amazing place,
on Central Park South.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Exactly.
And for me, it was
wonderful to be there,
because I could really access some
of Ellington's music,
scores, first-hand.
And of course it gave
me a good schooling
in the business of publishing.
>> Dan Morgenstern: You met
Ellington in Switzerland, right?
>> Abdullah Ibrahim:
Switzerland, yeah.
We were playing in this
little club, and we met a lot
of American musicians because
they passed through on concerts.
I met Gana [phonetic],
the Messengers,
that's when I first
met Wayne Shorter.
A lot of them came
through, Coltrane.
And the, but this club
that we played in,
we knew that Ellington was coming.
The club owner didn't want
to let us, let us off.
So Sathima went to the concert,
and we had finished, in fact,
the club owner was just
locking up when Sathima arrives
with Ellington and his entourage.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Wow.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: I don't
know today how she managed.
What did she say to Ellington?
But he came and, okay,
we went in the trio.
And I was asked to play,
and we played a few pieces.
And then a few days later he
took us to Paris to record.
He was ANR man for a [inaudible].
Frank Sinatra.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Right.
Right.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: It was
incredible because when we got
into the studio, he said to Sathima.
So what do you do?
And she said, I sing.
And he said okay, we'll
start with you.
And that's how we recorded, it was
recorded in the afternoon in Paris.
Which was then later,
later released.
It was not released
in the same time,
when my recording was released.
A learning experience.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Ellington
was an amazing man wasn't he?
He was just.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yeah he
was a, always, always remind me
of this wise old men in the village.
You have to watch what you say.
Like Mandela.
I was [inaudible] with Mandela,
when you apt not to say anything.
And when you start saying it, you
realize that you put your foot
in your mouth [laughter].
Because the old [inaudible]
and Ellington,
almost like the seven
sense of understanding,
or almost like foreseeing.
And I think it's maybe it's a
quality that we try to develop
as jazz musicians, this
almost anticipation,
not just in the music,
but in one's life.
To develop this propensity to see
in others what is deeply embedded,
and how we can resonate with such.
And Ellington was a master,
he was a master at that.
And also his response, you
know, how he would respond
to a situation was quite masterful.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Yeah,
he knew how to bring
out the special quality
in a musician.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yea.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Some
cases once they left him,
they never recaptured that.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim:
Yeah, from that.
Yeah, one of the things
that I learned from him is
that when I saw writing for why the
instrument's wider than the piano.
So you actually, you
write for the musician.
So you, that specific
ability or specific
that specific sonority
that a musician has.
And then write the song for
that specific individual,
instead of the other way round.
Instead of just writing
music, and at the same time,
people that have to play it.
And I think this is why he had this,
and of course, the great thing is,
was, that he had the
orchestra at his fingertips.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Well that's why,
you know, he kept that orchestra,
even though it, you know,
it cost him a fortune.
And he kept them on salary
even when they were not working
because he wanted that to be there
when he had music that
he wanted to hear.
And we're lucky that he did that.
And of course when he wasn't
recording for a label,
he recorded stuff for himself.
We have that whole
treasure trove of things.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: How do you
manage to keep these great musicians
with you such a long time?
So, [inaudible] I've got a gimmick.
I give them money [laughter].
And then be with them at the studio.
Because they paid them
out of his own,
out of his own, out
of his own pocket.
>> Dan Morgenstern: There's a
big literature about Ellington,
of course, and there's a recent
book I don't know if you've seen it,
but Terry Teachout about Duke,
and it's become quite
controversial with Ellington fans.
And I think rightly so.
Because among other things,
he says that Ellington was really
not a very good piano player,
I mean he was okay, but he was
no more than sort of mediocre.
Which is such a idiotic
thing to say, you know?
Because the sound alone
that he got out it.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yea.
I mean, listening to, listening
to Ellington and, like you say,
the sound, but the concept
of listening now to,
what did you just say, the
Ella, the Ellington [inaudible].
And one of the things that I leaned
from Ellington was
this comping, you know?
How to accompany a
singer or the soloist,
and it was quite incredible.
Because if you look at
just a simple song like,
Do Nothing To Hear From Me.
So there's a basic chords, you know,
but what he does is this inversion
of the chords and runs with you
[laughter] you never thought of.
But it, it, it does not interfere
with the spirit of the vocalist.
A lot of accompanies,
you know, will overcrowd.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Things he plays
in the cracks in an arrangement,
you know, just perfect enhancing.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: So that's a
pianist, and [inaudible] listen
to Ellington and then we always
are stunned and say, well,
why didn't I think about that?
I can imagine this as a
negative response [inaudible],
but I mean that is over because
they said Monk couldn't play either.
>> Dan Morgenstern: And Monk
was, really loved Ellington.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Yeah.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Yeah.
When you listen to the
1930s small group recordings
where Duke sometimes, you know,
stretches out a little more,
you can hear stuff that
Monk picked up from him.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim:
That's right, yeah.
And then [inaudible],
those were Ellington,
and then [inaudible] was the one
that really, the first musician
to endorse, to endorse Monk.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Monk, yeah.
I've seen the magazine, there
was a magazine called Music Dial,
which was published by
black musicians in Harlem,
it was a unique magazine,
the only one of its kind.
It lasted a couple of
years, it got started
in the mid 40s, very funny, 43.
And Herbie wrote a column so then
that's where he mentions Monk,
the first time he got
mentioned in print.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim:
Wow, I must look that up.
>> Dan Morgenstern:
Did you meet Herbie?
Did you know him?
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: No, I didn't.
I tried to play all his tunes
even in South Africa, you know,
the ten inch, the blue
note, ten inches.
The first time I went to Japan, you
remember those little jazz clubs
that they had, the size of
postage stamps all over Japan,
and I played this [foreign
language] way up in the winter.
I go into this club, little small,
little club, and the guy says,
is this, I've got everything.
I said [foreign language].
So I realize then that, I mean,
this music resonated well beyond,
beyond borders that we
maybe created for ourselves.
So when I was a, when I
first had [inaudible],
I tried to play some [inaudible],
but that already was pushing,
you know, it was pushing
the boundaries.
>> Dan Morgenstern:
Well it was lucky
that Bluno'd [phonetic] recorded her
because otherwise there would only
be a tiny amount of stuff of his.
He didn't have much luck,
he was such a nice man.
I met him through Roswell
Rudd, Roswell and Steve Lacy,
they loved Herbie, you know?
So tell me, what are you, what is
the next thing you are about to do?
>> Abdullah Ibrahim:
Tomorrow we go to New York,
we're there for a few days and
then we go to, with the band,
with [inaudible] and seven
piece, we do a US tour.
We go to San Francisco,
Seattle, where else are we going?
Dakota, Dakota Jazz Club, I
haven't been there for years.
Phoenix at the music museum, it's
a tour until about the 9th of May,
then I go back to Germany
and then we go to,
I go to South Africa do this project
with Musikkeller [assumed spelling]
with Ekaya, my band, and
Musikkeller [assumed spelling],
we do two nights.
And it is a commemoration
or maybe a revisiting
of the jazz episode recording
that we did in the late 50s,
and this is going to be perhaps
the beginning of a curriculum
for an academy that we
have been planning on
and working on for many years.
It looks now as if we have some,
or we've been having the support
from government and my,
my suggestion to them was
that we should really
invest in the academy.
And it looks as if we have it
together, so, coming to Library
of Congress, everybody
knows that I'm here.
And that I'm meeting with you,
and also how we can create this,
some kind of a synergy, you know,
because with this incredible wealth
of material that is here,
you know, especially in terms
of reading an academy,
especially for young musicians.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Yeah we, we
really, we need good, good teachers,
we need to transmit the tradition.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: So we've been
doing it with Ekaya, you know,
with my, with the band,
whenever we travel,
like I said, we have workshops.
>> Dan Morgenstern: You do clinics?
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Clinics, yeah.
The problem is that there's
no follow through, you see.
So you do it for the concert,
or, and then it's gone.
So there's no follow through,
and this is what, we need,
need this academy, of
course a total agreement
that the most important aspect
of this is getting the teachers
and mentors who firstly
know the tradition
and who are passionate about it.
So I think, I think we've,
this visit here to the Library
of Congress has opened up a
very possible [inaudible].
And I'm speaking to you and I
just, your expertise and your,
your [inaudible] knowledge
that you have
of the music and its environment.
>> Dan Morgenstern: I've just been
very lucky because I never thought
when I was first became
interested in jazz and, you know,
from recordings and see, I had the
good luck of seeing Fats Waller
in Copenhagen when I was not quite
9 years old and he blew me away.
But I never thought I would be
able to make a living out of that,
but I started writing and then it's
just one thing led to another and,
you know, it's a blessing to
have been able to make a living
at something that you really love
and the music is so, you know,
I still, you know,
I still get a kick
out of my Louis Hot
Fives [laughter].
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: [inaudible]
how the music, there's a filmmaker,
John Irving, he's asked me to do,
to write some music for a film.
And we were talking about this, he
said, when he was 14 years of age,
he heard Ellington in London
and there was a singer with him,
it was a blind singer, but
he never knew what he was,
and I said, Al Hibbler.
And that led me to the Liberian
Suite, you see with Al Hibbler "I
Like the Sunrise", being blind.
So until you, Liberian Suite, I
don't know if it is performed much.
>> Dan Morgenstern: No.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: But that is
one of the works for his uncle,
[inaudible] the Liberian Suite,
and get this interconnectedness
that has happened,
happened with the music.
And especially for teaching,
for it to be in the curriculum.
So we can understand that the,
the music in the diaspora
is far and wide.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Yeah,
there's such a wealth of stuff,
such a treasure trove of music
that can be introduced to people,
and especially to young musicians
who very often are totally amazed
when they come into contact with
some of the past that, you know,
we had at Rutgers University
where there is a master's
program in jazz history.
And then somebody saying they heard,
for the first time, "Weather Bird",
which is a beautiful thing with
Earl Hines and Louis together.
They were doing that in 1928?
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: I agree, it's
absolutely imperative that we,
that there must be some
vehicle, this should be passed
onto the other generation.
>> Dan Morgenstern: Well, it's
been wonderful to see you again,
and I hope it won't be another
60 years before we do [laughter],
it was so good to see you.
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Thank you
for this, thank you for your time.
>> Dan Morgenstern: I look
forward to hearing more
of your beautiful music live and
recordings and all the best to you.
We're both, I'm a little
older than Abdullah,
we're both oxygenarians [laughter],
but we're still doing it right?
>> Abdullah Ibrahim: Still
doing it We're blessed.
Thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.